oui
il conçoit diagonale spécial vichy
dernière émission ce soir et je suis
avec le champion de france et le vice
champion de france 2000 avec donc le
grand maître etienne bacrot on sort
etienne pour soi et donc iossif dorfman
bonsoir donc je rappelle aussi dorman ex
entraîneur de kasparov et d' etienne
bacrot alors était une macro à jouer
aujourd'hui contre son ex entraîneur la
partie décisive de de ce championnat
fallait absolument ne pas perdre pour
éviter les matchs de départage alors
comment ça s'est passé la préparation de
cette partie c'était assez difficile de
me préparer parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai joué un peu pour la nulle comme
j'avais un point d'avancé
et puis c'est toujours dur de jouer
contre un entraîneur puisque iosif
connais très bien mon répertoire et
j'avais un petit peu peur
un petit peu peur dans le début puis
finalement ça s'est bien passé
et de votre côté et aussi comment ça
s'est passé cette préparation
oui il est applaudi respect déjà même si
je gagne je sur rien et je ne veux pas
perdre aussi est bon tout le monde parle
que je peux proposer nul à n'importe
quel moment je ne sais pas comme ça
c'est la passion des perdants je ne peux
pas proposer un nul donc
je décide de jouer aux échecs que
correct mais c'est une préparation
spéciale parce que on ne peut pas
planifier la victoire avec les noirs
contre un fort jouèrent et mais on en
vit toujours donc quand j'ai regardé 2
hir plusieurs ouvertures à chaque fois
j'ai hésité je rejetais j'ai changé à
mon avis quelques fois j'ai déjà décidé
hier soir après j'ai changé dans la
matinée après je changer encore une fois
et finalement j'ai pris la décision de
voler chéquier déjà et il ya encore je
n'ai pas été sur non je pensais qu'elle
tienne elle va jouer cette variante
c'était pratiquement clair pour moi
alors on va y revenir lui aussi tout à
l'heure parce qu'on va commenter la
partie donc on pourra revenir sur les
moments nous les deux de cette partie
revanche voudrais revenir sur la
particularité de du classement de cette
année donc premier etienne bacrot
deuxième missile dorfman donc
l'entraîneur et puis l'élève est aussi
le champion de france 98
il y aussi le dorfman contre champion de
france de l'année dernière etienne
bacrot ça fait beaucoup de
particularités pour ce match est ce que
c'est vraiment particulier c'est la
première fois que ça arrive comme ça que
les autant de d'importance sur sur un
seul match en plus à la dernière ronde
comme ça hors etienne j'ai pas comment
tu as est ce que tu es ce que tu pensé à
tout ça quand tu veux jouer cette partie
oui mais beaucoup d'importance cette
dernière ronde
mais bon c'est pas la première fois dans
un championnat de france que qu'on a
qu'on a des problèmes comme ça avec
iosif des gérants 98 on était tout près
et puis finalement c'est iosif qui avait
gagné
et puis là c'est vrai que là on joue et
on jouait ensemble pour la première
place mais bon j'avais quand même un bel
avantage puisque j'ai un point d'avancé
je joue avec les blancs bon c'était
c'était un peu ils sont tous comme ça
sur tomber c'est vrai le tournoi s'est
joué dans les dernières rondes puisque
lui aussi fait moi on n'était pas très
bien parti et finalement on finit tous
les deux très bien puisque bon je finis
avec trois ennemis iosif avec 3 sur 4 a
frappé sanguine n'a pas perdu de partie
alors que toi tu as perdu contre donc
jean-marc degraeve dans la lors de la
première poule j'ai perdu avant la
journée de repos
la septième round quand jean-marc
degraeve c'est peut-être ce qui m'a
motivé après pour gagner mes autres
partis j'avais simplement plus le choix
puis ça s'est bien passé
d'accord il ya aussi peut-être est-ce
que est ce que les rondes d'hier et
d'avant-hier ont pas décidé un petit peu
de ski de la suite des événements
c'était trop dur peut-être aujourd'hui
gagné avec les noirs c'est très dur de
jeux gagnés avec la noix comme une bombe
2006 est ce que est ce que hier ou
avant-hier il y avait pas la possibilité
de remonter de je crois qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai reçu une position du joueur qui est
déjà un succès avec la noire dans une
telle situation est par exemple je
préfère l'impression que non aujourd'hui
par l'impulsion dire contre les graves
avec les blancs projet pour gagner
non c'est pas ça qui décident moi je
pense que j'ai joué cette ouverture mais
pas exactement cet ordre du coup mais
cette structure est ce type de pression
je veux beaucoup
la détiennent peut-être actuelle et j'ai
bien senti peut-être cette pression dans
les années 70 après j'ai arrêté je sais
pas pourquoi je ne vais pas
l'explication j'ai arrêté et aujourd'hui
je pense que je fais tous les coups
qu'il fallait faire mais ç'a pris du
temps quand même et dans la citation
final je vais petit difficile du temps
après un quart d'heure la différence je
pense que l'on peut continuer la partie
tout est possible je sais pas qui ai mis
mon avis tout est possible le point
final et après mais bon c'était normal
et si on parle il y à un championnat
riesch championne entraîneur annexe
élèves et cetera je peux rajouter encore
un truc j'ai regardé aujourd'hui tout à
coup je me promenais dans la matinée et
j'ai regardé l'adresse du motel c'est la
rue de la russie numéro 2 13 pas mal en
quoi pas mal donc c'était un signe
peut-être alors alors été par contre ce
que tu crois aussi ça fait donc deux ans
que tu es champion de france a envie de
faire la passe de trois pour l'année
prochaine
bah on verra l'an prochain ses pensées
c'est la troisième année que je joue tu
penses que rejouer l'année prochaine aux
menaces un tournant qui te plaît pas
planter là encore cette année c'était
très fort oui manqué joël mais sinon les
meilleurs meilleurs joueurs étaient là
dès que pourquoi pas l'an prochain un
nouveau nationale et la suite des
évènements s'annonce bien parce que je
crois que tu es tu qualifié ca d'office
pour le championnat du monde oui il ya
des places pour les moins de 20 ans qui
ont plus de 2600 donc grâce à mon
classement de juin je suis qualifié
directement pour les championnats du
monde d'accord donc ça va ça va être
intéressant aussi à suivre le champion
de france aux championnats du monde donc
à new delhi c'est ça a été rendu mais
semble alors on va voir tout de suite on
va revenir
évidemment on va discuter de ce titre de
ce nouveau titre 2000 donc le champion
de france 99 va garder son titre on va
voir tout de suite la partie
d'aujourd'hui
voilà entre etienne bacrot you s'il dort
mal donc je rappelle qu etienne avait un
point d'avancé sur youphil dorfman et
donc c'est plutôt iossif qui devait
essayer de gagner cette partie pour
éventuellement jouer les départage donc
essayer de jouer une ouverture b qui
permettent
de compliqué je suppose la position pour
essayer de surprendre etienne si c'était
possible
c'est difficile effectivement de
surprendre deux joueurs qui se
connaissent si bien un élève et un ex
entraîneur vous avez forcément beaucoup
d'affinités oui bon je pense que iosif
sait très bien ce que je même si ça fait
ou on a fait un stage cette année même
si ça fait deux ans qu'on n'avait pas
vraiment travailler mais c'est vrai que
encore beaucoup de ma préparation c'est
ce qu'on avait analysé avec iosif donc
encore une grande partie de mon
répertoire et celui d'il ya deux ans
d'accord alors donc d4 joie détiennent
au premier coup ensuite cavalier pts 6
donc là on s'oriente vers une défense
soit grünfeld soit soit estonienne
probablement encore le regard caustique
tout ce que ces quatre il ya pas eu
d'hésitation j'ai vu sur les premiers
coups j'ai ce g si c'était prévu on
avait joué quelques parties ensemble il
ya deux ans trois ans mais bon c'était
des gambie dame qui durait dix couches
crasse creux de plus devant je pensais
je pensais aussi que l'ast indienne
s'était c'était un choix possible pour
yousif alors qu'avril ces trois ans
lorsque là on peut s que aussi vous avez
envisagé de faire la grüne fail c'est
plutôt annulant la brise pas d'étoilé à
quelques ouvertures comme chiffres
d'octobre on peut dire comme congrès en
fait les blancs peuvent faire nul par
n'importe quel moyen de pratiquement
toutes les lignes principales
foot espagnol et quatre sur les os et
encore et encore donc il fallait
forcément essayer l'estonienne mais avec
une bonne préparation nul et contre
n'importe qui d'un coup bien sûr de
l'estonien c'est plus compliqué donc
déjà premier choix donc important
effectivement donc lui aussi joue pour
le guen donc avec fougue et 7 suivi donc
2e 4 qui le coût normal a priori des six
cavaliers f3 donc la petit rock foo e 2
e 5 petit rock et là aussi vous avez
réfléchi vous avez réfléchi longtemps
d'ailleurs si au moins un quart d'heure
au verger franchement la maison j'ai
réussi des sujets que je et cavaliers 6
je vais cavaliers c6 mais je n'ai pas
d'éléments ainsi à toute la journée
parce que je sais qu'elle tienne elle
travaille énormément sur justement sur
cette position dit il est allé très bons
résultats
moi je ne vois pas davantage aujourd'hui
dans ce système pour les blancs j'ai dit
déjà après la partie contre hanovre
mais aujourd'hui c'est pas le mieux
c'est pas mon objectif pour montrer que
les noirs résiste bien dans cette danse
est très récente et je cherchais quelque
chose peu plus compliqué pour jouer tout
simplement pas compliquer les choses
et encore j'ai lu si on attend donc que
j'adore le livre de chroniques donc je
le regarde tous les jours pratiquement g
et quel âge et une partie avec la vallée
à 6 c'est mon coup suivant alors il ya
six mois il dans les commentaires que je
jouais plusieurs fois cette variante
avec les blancs et je trouve qu'il n'ya
pas de lien direct qui offrait un
avantage ou blanc donc pourquoi pas
essayer avec le noir c'est l'armée qui
dit à ce moment-là etienne reste que ce
coup sata sur free est-ce que tu t'y
attendais ou pas ou est ce que là est ce
que tu es confiant pour la suite ou pas
bon c'était j'ai pas mal travaillé hier
pour savoir ce que ce que iosif pouvait
jouer et puis bon c'est vrai que j'ai
regardé quand même sur cavaliers à 6 un
peu un peu l'ouverture
moi j'étais j'étais quand même
un peu surpris parce que j'ai pas vu
deux parties comme ça j'en ai pas vu
mais puis j'ai quand même je suis un peu
préparé sur ce système puisque cavaliers
à 6 et le coût que je vais beaucoup
vladislav tkachiev comme on s'entend
bien on a regardé un petit peu cette
position donc sur privé mais pape a
perdu finalement n'ont pas donné la
jeunesse
nous avons les analyses que moi mais
quand même on avait commencé à
travailler sur ce système aussi ensemble
j'ai quelques aline sûrement dans
l'alimentaire et a pas vraiment s'il
attire je laisse vient de très bien
on s'aimait rapidement d'abord on avait
travaillé aussi d'accord donc on est
toujours un terrain connu pour les
joueurs donc ensuite si on peut voir la
suite tout rehaussé à 5 ou souple il ya
d'autres variantes contre 98 donc c'est
6 oui moi je joue avec les blancs une
autre ligne contre cavalli racisme est
bon torrent c'est normal c'est très sale
et dessus alors fouet fin après pions
prend des quatre donc là c'est une
décision central de la tour dans la
partie est
s'il sait que les ivor il avait joué
fuji quel âge est fou j'ai quatre
généraux parti n'est pas très bien
oui évidemment que sur ce niveau on ne
peut pas être très naïf il s'appuie sur
les pertes de votre adversaire parce que
évidemment qu'il a analysé plusieurs
fois les parties qu'elles avaient perdu
donc c'est le plus stupide qui existent
par exemple j'ai regardé la partie des
tirs contre palau à ses rêves et dans un
nom donné est une amélioration est
absolument évident on ne tienne elle est
arrêtée pendant la partie peut-être est
bien de ne risquez rien les blancs sont
mieux tout simplement donne évidemment
que je regarde les parties je cherche
des idées mais on ne peut pas bêtement
répéter
déjà connu de la dire oui même s'il
avait perdu c'est à dire y en je peux
jouer plutôt la structure qu'il n'aime
pas mais pas absolument les mêmes coûts
non parce qu'il a forcé il a analysé
donc depuis et il risque à sortir
quelque chose de mieux
non mais comment comment j'ai réfléchi
si je refais roja 4
tout sera connu et il va jouer avait
demandé 5 c'est clair et après c'est à
moi de trouver quelque chose de nouveau
et je ne crois pas dans cette pression
avec avec les noirs parfois quatre des
cinq jugés sans aucune pression avec les
blancs secs et les blancs sont mieux la
barbe est donc comme comme j'ai écrit
dans le commentaire de ma partie contre
h cause qui dans mon premier livre
seulement avec le son des rovers ont pu
achever ce type de pollution à mon avis
d'accord tout le choix doit être c'est
pas facile mais c'est le sol chinois
d'accord donc tu apprends des quatre car
il prend des quatre cavaliers j4 donc la
cec connue encore c'est le coût normal
mais je crois on en avait discuté en 98
de cette position pendant pendant le
tournoi zonal ce que iosif devait jouer
blanc contre quelqu'un contre neighbour
justement contre commence à courir comme
un fou pour gagner à partir de ces
niveaux là et puis m'avait demandé si tu
me maîtriser davantage c'est ici mesurer
nos jeunes compétiteurs jeunes étage le
4e premier coup
d'accord je n'ai pas décidé que ça donc
h3 il a le coup d'un v6 qui fait une
contre attaque sur le cavalier centrale
donc là on est obligé de prendre le
clavier henri iv oui d'accord pion au
grand dam est roi mais voilà ta meuf
trop haut et fort c'est ça ou non le
taux normal c'est g5
mais bon pendant la partie je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé j'ai très rapidement
de m 3 ah bon c'est bizarre dans ma
préparation c'est g5
moi je sais que iosif avait quelque
chose de préparer sur ce coup mais mais
quand même il fallait que j'ouvre un
accord dont peut alors dames seront
alors c'est quoi donc si ça sort de la
préparation c'est une erreur c'est un
manque d'attention
j'étais jeune ça déjà dû à dieu vient
déjà les portes mais bon pour moi
préparation c'était g5 ah bon donc c'est
un changement d'accord dame f3 d'un v6
oui le plus souvent le noir jo dames 5
mais j'ai pensé que ce coup il est bon
parce que je ne laisse pas développé le
faut c'est un et sites urbains et les
appétits de combinaisons sur tourbe un
aléa propre rangé qatar donc je ne
laisse pas développé en ce moment la
belle dame la golf au projet 4 puisque
si d'emprunt il ya foot rocca serra et
le pion bedo est cloué par l'adam
oui mais voilà eloi et loire lange qui
est aux manettes nous montre la variante
il faut prendre cavaliers et on peut pas
reprendre le fou puisque la dame
prendrait la tour donc faire attention
il ya des petits pièges lors dans cette
position finalement j'avais pas trop le
choix
j'ai joué dans me2 donc voir il faut
bien que je sorte mon fou et puis pour
protéger b2c pas facile autres mais
évidemment est-ce que c'est pas une
perte de temps on a joué deux fois la
dame
ben si c'est pour ça qu'en voyant le
ku'damm b6 j'ai commencé à avoir un
petit peu peur mais heureusement a
dangereusement d'un modèle apple lg
d'amos et un collier d'un bus d'accord
un monde de veysonnaz y avait déjà une
petite fête alors il y avait un petit
doute sur la validité de la suite à non
bah oui parce que je cherchais quelque
chose de plus solide quand même mais je
pense qu'après j'ai 5 c soit une finale
soit je peux développer mes pièces plus
facilement que qui s'est quand même ici
c'est jouable
émond pendant un parti j'ai eu un petit
peu peur quand même c'est une logique
d'accord donc une petite frayeur à 6
mois sur tout et surtout que je me suis
souvenu que qu'il fallait que jugé cinq
ans vers d'un v6 j'ai compris que
j'étais plus dans ma préparation
d'accord à ce moment là tu es sortie de
teint de ta préparation fouet 3 est
normal on développe un fou on attaque la
dame dames c'est cette la f3 alors ça
c'est un coup de consolidation s'est
passé c'est qu'elle est l'idée c'est de
peut-être replié de fous aussi
maintenant il faut il faut protéger
bon sur vos protégés g4 protéger 4 et 4
également c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
joué g5 g5 était peut-être possible
est-ce qu'on affaiblit pas les cases
noires aussi autour du roi blanc est ce
que ça peut pas être un motif d' attaque
ouais mais bon
mais je suis là il faut sauver les pions
face au vélodrome donc on s'est un peu
un coup sauf meuble peut alors ça donc
cavalier c'est normal stora d1 donc le
développement se termine au feu 5 il
faut 5 kg des six aussi est là donc ça
fonctionne protège protège le plan des
six dames c2 alors on a une pression
quand même sur cette position ils
dorfman que le fou s'est vite a du mal à
trouver à trouver ces casses de
développement vous savez un jeu g est
remonté à propos de la partie espagnole
qui est le faussaire dans la partie
espagnole et les deux pas de la
naissance ne doit pas bouger il est déjà
développé en scène si c'est pareil le
français il fallait déjà développé
pourquoi la touche et je joue tout
simplement le pion à adopter ou la tour
on va voir maintenant quelques
comploteurs jeune dacquois donc c'est
pas la peine de sorte de bougies se fout
mal et blanc et fisher hospitalisés je
crois que ce fou on le sort pour faire
maths c'est ça donc des recettes
voilà qui va lieu de carrillo dehors ça
ça colle matin petit peu les cases
noires un sabotage et 3 heureusement
heureusement qu'il y avait lieu de 11
mois parce qu'il ya le secret facebook
voilà y'a si elle s'affiche aussi à quel
sacrifice d'un match 4 d'un match 4 il
ya g 3g sera dur faut prendre g3 fait
projet trois autres qui va les prendre
dans prende mg deux dames g2 et mons
maintenant c'est nettement mieux pour
les blancs parce qu'il ya le pion des
six qui les cache noir c'est le cas
c'est fini maintenant par exemple dames
5 damage de encore je sais pas et si le
temps le plan des six tombes forcément 4
d'accord ok non mais ça il ne faut pas
calculer d'un match il faisait 4 il va
remonter en outre ils se sont peut-être
comme ça
la finale parce que même les charges de
dames d'accord donc on peut pas jouer
d'un match 4 à cause de jets 3 et c'est
un pseudo sacrifices depuis évidemment
mais je prends le pion mais c'est passé
d'accord ryan corps et âme à m'en
excuser moi n'ont pas discuté mais
peut-être avant j'avais encore fujitsu
lieu demain 7 mai fu et vidéo peut-être
et même le sacrifice de qualité même
soif de sur les changes et les fouilles
et se retrouve à changer le regard des 6
d'accord on peut jouer faux et deux
autres dans la ville protection des
cases noires mais donc le pian 2 des 6
est faible c'est ça lorsque le faux 5
est plus fort que le feu trois contrôles
bien des 6 et puis d'accord donc ça
serait une bonne opération pour les
blancs de l'échangé mais le problème
c'est que je peux pas je me fous des
catés faut prendre 5 parce que les noms
vont prendre du plan d'aidé sans
faiblesse après vous comprenez on devait
pas échanger les faux no 5 parce que les
blancs et nous on est les noirs ils vont
reprendre avec le pilote des 6es la case
des 4 vallées réussissent des donc le
fourgon touchable pour déstabiliser les
noirs il faut faire f4 absolument ouvrir
la pression complètement c'est ça le
problème pour le plan d'accord donc là à
donc ça c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure donc on développe pas le feu
s'est vite mon active la tour avec eux à
l'exception c'est ça l'idée quand j'ai
réfléchi ici j'ai bien compris que je ne
peux pas attaquer les rois en ateliers
proposés mais à mon avis les blancs sont
beaucoup plus forts centre de laquelle
la concentration des pièces blanches au
centre je ne vois pas que je peux percer
quand je perds ce n'importe quel moment
et les f4 faut prendre ça sent qu'ils
ressentent donc c'est trop risqué
je vais pas me permettre mais par contre
le cavalier se trouait l'équité les
dames la torah aussi il est plombé des
ados sont faibles donc il y à un plant
pour attaquer les pions ado et bédié
voyons ça je dois pour cette descente
mettre le pied dans l'encadré percée b5
peut rouvrir pour vairelles dame
retrouver la dame n'a cocan et apprécie
les blancs elles vont élire nouveau les
pièces l'album attaqué le roi en son nom
tous d'accord donc
donc l'idée c'est de créer des brèches
de côté elle nomme tous les droits à
l'air bien les blancs et puis en même
temps il faut éviter b4 c'était du temps
d'une saison
dans l'ensemble c'est forcément j'ai dit
encore le coach et moi non plus ça fait
partie d'un plan qui a quatre de cinq
ans donc très bien alors donc à 5 alors
on sait plus où on en est là j'ai loi g3
c'est simple mais la g35 est à 4
vraiment il ya un petit truc tactique 6
des 9 6 qui attaquent deux pions à
l'adversaire est meilleur possible à
cause de f4 la clôture de l'entente
attend attaque le quéau f3 et le pion b2
d'accord donc six f4 cardia f4 faut
prendre b2 faut prendre méiose toujours
ya toujours eu 5 voilà a eu 5 et le trou
et coupez pas bien mais on gagne la
pièce 1 voilà ça revient dans plusieurs
variantes donc d'accord donc c'est pas
une grande variantes mais c'est bon
aussi fait pas tomber dans le piège
d'accord ok d'attendre quelques années à
4 et
c'est terminé là non voilà qui propose
des nieulles donc pourquoi je propose un
nul je vois que les blancs peuvent
facilement faire encore une série du
coup comme s'ils voulaient g5 vogel aux
mêmes préparez vous car à terre tandis
que par les noirettes photos vers un
plan le plan est lié avec besson je vois
pas ici l'intérêt des personnes 5 c'est
la folie complètement à cause gfg faut
prendre ces cinq après au f4 d'abord il
faut prendre valait 5 qui va ruiner les
noyales l es le roi et la structure des
pions donc il faut j'ai pour b 5 mes5
c'est pas facile etienne il propose
place et de cavaliers en f4 ou peut-être
je sens que moi je moi je pensais je
sens qu'il faut faire attention aussi
après fou g2 souvent à prévessin qui
apprend prend f4e 5 bien sûr je peux
tout ouvrir et moi j'ai les pièces bien
placé comme je ne crois pas qu'il faille
les f4 à mon avis ils vont me faisait
bouger de d'abord où j'ai dû jouer après
les premiers de coûts mais même je sens
j'ai pensé l'idée c'est de jouer
4 c'est ça ton nom elle quand on est
faux pas pour l'instant d'accord faut
mais c'est vrai que pour trouver un plan
avec les noirs c'est assez difficile
veut sur b5 maintenant peut-être prise
prises et f4 maintenant c'est même saisi
moment possible brise fr à tv5
non mais je crois que c'est un petit peu
au théâtre et aux cinq qui avait le fou
g2 qui se réveille sur la torah bien sûr
pourquoi pas tomber vite au lieu des 5
ou peut-être trouvé peut-être pour bill
qui menace b5 et auront besoin c'est ça
qui m'intéresse
d'accord mais donc là les chances et
aussi vous avez estimé que les chances
de pour les noirs de monter l'attaqué
tait
probablement les où je peux donner mon
avis je n'ai pas analysé bien sûr cette
partie comme etienne je donne
l'impression après les parties du corps
que le noir ils ont réussi de créer une
position combative c'est tout ce que
tout ce que je peux dire à propos de
cette pollution
quelle est la position je sais pas mais
mais je n'ai pas joué dans cet esprit
depuis des années j'ai hérité cette
vertu rejeté assez fort dans les années
70 c'était c'était ma variante toujours
où j'ai remporté plusieurs victoires
pouvait trouver dans la première livre
les commentaires de ma pratique
antérieure course qui était très très
semblables ici il mais maintenant je
vois qu'aujourd'hui j'ai fait quelques
coups avec les difficultés j'ai réfléchi
quand même beaucoup c'est pour la
première fois si vous avez vraiment que
je vais très rapidement oui les autres
partis jamais dans cette note même sous
la menace de notre aujourd'hui c'était
déjà très proches et je me suis dit que
ça se fume et en plus devant il faut
dire que c'est le genre de position que
tu joue beaucoup au blanc aussi c'est ce
que j'ai beaucoup appris dans ce genre
de position à l'explosif il me faisait
jouer ces choses là
alors si on les entoure grâce à cette
partie nul donc keating macro gagne le
championnat avec donc un point d'avancé
une performance à 2687 points si je me
trompe pas et il gagne 10 points loup
c'est pas mal au classement c'est pas
mal il faudra juste
c'est sûr que maintenant les points
valent très cher oui parce que là pour
moi ça me fait du bien
nature entier dans l'est dans les 100
meilleurs joueurs du monde 36e sont si
souvent beaucoup beaucoup plus - avec
2006 je sais 86e lille doit être avec
2623 quelques mois
l'exil m non mais avec 2613 c'est 66e 23
donc la vallée 10 points de plus
certains points que j'ai gagné en fait
savoir en perdant contre alpha si
lieberman patients drilles en argile
voilà oui il avait un classement
tellement super attaquant même gagnant
perdant le match trop et demi deux ans
et demi j'ai gagné un point bon c'est
pas très important mais bon ça france -
quand même d'accord alors qu'est ce
qu'il reste à jouer pour pour le
prochain que la place prochaine façon
assez en janvier c'est aujourd'hui il va
trouver ça jouer quoi le les olympiades
peut-être un match contre short un match
pour nos chances à un mois à la mère
d'abord on a organisé ça sera au mois
d'octobre
oui et puis après je vais me préparer
pour les championnats du monde et les
olympiades non je sais pas il ya encore
beaucoup de questions puisque c'est
seulement une semaine avant le
championnat du monde donc si je veux
arriver bien préparé
oui et en forme va falloir faire un
choix quand même du temps je peux pas je
peux pas tout faire
je vais réfléchir donc un match contre
short très intéressant je pense qu'on en
israël type de diagonale peut-être on
essaiera d'y aller pour filmer ça et
donc le championnat du monde où on
espère que tu passeras plusieurs tours
et pourquoi pas arriver en finale on
sait pas c'est possible
ouais ça serait bien de jouer à terre
pas de preuve alors on continue sur ton
parcours puisque on va voir maintenant
une dot est parti donc bio si dortmund
va rester avec nous évidemment puisqu'il
communalité ton entraîneur il pourra
aussi commenté commenté tes choix je
pense d'eux qu'on va avoir une partie
que tu as joué contre laurent frayssinet
quantique osier qui était joué quand il
y a
après ma défaite après défaite contre le
hamas est donc la première partie de la
poule aux deux premières parties de la
plante donc ça c'est important tu venais
de perdre contre jean-marc degraeve donc
tu avais un demi point de retard sur
arnaud hauchard christ en bouère à ce
moment-là ex-aequo donc on était
plusieurs églises de rite écossais ça
donc je n'avais pas trop le choix il
fallait il fallait donc j'ai alors on va
voir vers cette partie contre laurent
frayssinet peut-être pas toute la partie
peut-être le moment de critiques
je sais pas combien de coups elle fait
exactement une petite seconde là avant
la partie encore d'autres peut-être une
minute on n'a pas encore la partie non
d'accord donc et loi cherche la partie
dans la base de la base de données donc
c'était la partie la première ronde de
la de la poule haute
alors est ce que cette formule de
championnat vous a plu à tous les deux
cette nouvelle formule de championnat
donc poule e des poules de qualification
et les quatre premiers de chaque poule
se rencontrent en poule haute
est ce que ça vous a plu bah pour moi ça
serait ça serait mieux je trouve ça plus
plus justin toute ronde
donc bon si c'est pas avec un joueur et
15 secondes peut-être peut-être un peu
moins peut-être deux joueurs et aux
rondes mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
assez juste aussi même si et même si les
points qu'on a fait contre les joueurs
de la peau de base sont pas les mêmes
non pas la même valeur pour chaque
groupe
mais puis c'est vrai c'est vrai que avec
cette formule à la fin
bonjour je tout tous les meilleurs et
chaque point chaque point est très très
important donc c'est assez intéressant
aussi question de goût la corde iossif
je t'offre pour me remous je vais dire
que les tiennes elle a mérité sa
victoire pour né pas
comme fonde la critique de cette formule
avec les résultats détiennent la formule
elle est complètement stupide à mon avis
il ya deux choses absolument
inadmissible je sais pas qu'ils
fabriquent les choses pareilles terry
qu'il ait rien à faire donc je les
cherche une nouvelle formule à chaque
fois donc vous donne déjà les groupes ne
sont pas forcément équilibré
je sais pas lequel est plus fort mais
c'est pas c'est pas du tout le même
groupe
après il faut jouer et réfléchir est-ce
que vous passez dans le pilote de la
poule basse qui empêche de prendre le
risque
il ya quelque parti ou jamais arrête
comme contre rdpc l'a jamais géré dans
une telle pression que je vois un net
avantage mais je ne peux pas prendre
tout simplement le risque vous me
retrouver dans la poule basse est encore
dans la dernière ronde du groupe
préliminaire et les légionnaires qui
sont obligés de prendre le risque et qui
donne des cadeaux aux joueurs qui m'ont
donné pour l'autre et qui bénéfice après
comme par exemple nataf et léger à la
dernière ou encore marc siano à
marseille c'est la folie donc après il
mène le championnat
comment on peut faire les choses
pareilles c'est sûr que c'est plus juste
en tout seront de toute façon non mais
là plusieurs formules même effacé les
résultats pourquoi dans le championnat
du monde de foot on ne compte pas les
matchs de [ __ ] préliminaire vous avez
eu la chance vous avez tombé dans un
groupe moins fort d'accord tant pis mais
après on oublie on joue à nouveau ici
hong kong les manches chaque équipe il
comme ici le joueur ils sont obligés se
battre pour la poule haute
ils prennent des risques ils dans les
cadeaux et après on ne peut pas on peut
pas compter les parties par et comment
on peut contenir cette victoire de
l'inter contre
merci annoncé pas cela comme un d'accord
bon mais c'est un avis ça fait qu'on est
con écoutez moi je n'ai pas d'avis
particulier
par contre on va voir maintenant
donc cette partie donc voilà je jouais
contre laurent frayssinet donc laurent
leahy blanche ça voilà donc le théâtre
j'ai joué ce que je veuille plusieurs
années wayne chris des six des quatre
s'éprend des quatre car elle y prend les
fils rouges et 5 e 6 donc tout ça c'est
la théorie
dakar 6 camp rock justice voilà qui va
les prendre c'est 6 donc je pense que
j'ai été le premier à perdre avec les
noirs contre cette variante est joué ça
contre ces gauches thain qui m'avait
jouer ça à l'époque c'était c'était une
nouveauté
il m'avait joué 196 dans un spi rapide à
fourmies voilà donc j'en prends ses
forces et maintenant c'est très à la
mode avec un dessin quatre des cinq
dames à 3,23 à ce moment là toujours
aussi connu pour toi 7 me
bien sûr c'est bien connu et donc après
cette partie on avait on avait travaillé
travaillé un petit peu avec iosif sur
cette position
oui on qui s'en souvient très bien aussi
mais bon j'ai quand même pris un risque
en jouant ça c'est risqué mais pourquoi
pourquoi un risque à ce moment là parce
que vous faut dire que la position n'est
pas n'est pas très bonne pour les
générales c'était très dangereux mais
après quelques coups a pris quelques
mains maintenant c'était cette variante
l'ag avait quasiment arrêté de jouer ça
avec les noirs à cause de cette nouvelle
variante bon moi je complètement arrêter
ce jeu c'est à côté
c'est la seule la seule explication que
nous ayons c'est pas mal de paume
oui je vais devoir gagner presque toutes
les parties avec n'avait toujours de
bonnes positions avec cette ouverture
et c'est vrai que ça nous embête est un
petit peu même beaucoup s'arrêtent donc
fawcett
ensuite je vois là un petit rock h4h 4
et puis maintenant je crois que tour
vite c'est un peu nouveau bon ça c'est
intéressant
voilà alors l'idée l'idée pour les noirs
ça va être ça va être quoi d'activer la
majorité de pion central
oui bah déjà il faut contenir les droits
parce que les blancs menacé quand même
g4 g5 et puis vent pour ce
on va essayer de jouer 5 d'accord donc
s'il y des tours 8
donc lâché 3 après maints enfin il ya
quelques quelques heures laurent m'a
proposé g4 à la place de dan g3 g4
cavaliers 17e 5
bon la brute mais mais c'est jouable
j'ai 4 gsm en page et 5,5 pour éviter
sérieux 5 pour éviter que les noirs eux
mêmes jouent à cinq si on rajoute 5.5
d'abord et qui a l'air de gagner le fou
le pion d'accord voilà il m'a proposé
sommes donc ça c'était une barre est
possible aussi qu'on va faire c'est sûr
c'est dangereux mais on n'a pas le choix
quand on doit gagner avec les noirs il
faut jouer le risque est d'accord donc
la mg3 donc la légère prévient michel 3
sans l'aide d'un lasso clouté g45 oui
c'est pour ça que bon c'est sûr que mes
pièces vont pas être très bien placé
après mais il a plus la possibilité de
jouer g4 g5 donc j'étais j'ai été un peu
plus tranquille ne plus avoir à me
préoccuper de cette attaque
d'accord donc nous après 3,8 c'est
obligé puisque à lifou princesse qui
mena dans mes pièces vont pas être très
bien placé mais avec le centre je pense
que c'est juin pour une 3 8 pouces et
cette dame 17 donc vous et 7,5 ou
normale d'un groupe pour déstabiliser un
peu la dame noire
ouais sinon sinon je vais je vais fois
fuite et j'aurai la possibilité de jouer
cavalier 17 avec la demande est d'accord
donc je me fous et huit mois j'ai pas le
choix donc le plan ces dames s'étaient
cavaliers 17 d'accord dames 7 km et 7
pour contrôler le 15 mars entre et
pouvoir pousser le cerveau là pour
pouvoir relancer les mains et donc ici
laurent il avait pas vu cette idée donc
de qui là il est il n'a pas essayer de
la contrer - il y avait peut-être des
possibilités avec fouet trois dames
cette tour h 20 des choses comme ça je
sais pas exactement si c'était possible
de jouer comme ça avec les blancs mais
il fallait pas jouer autour des 4 de
toute façon il a joué donc tour des
quatre alors voilà parce que maintenant
au mans après dams est cette idée donc
la lie des peaux noires se joue qu'à 17
m6 et aux 5 c'est sa soif 6,5 soit
prendre le pouls simplement est bon les
blancs n'ont pas d'attaqué puis les
noirs au centre la paire nous faut donc
normalement ça devrait n'ont cessé mais
peut-être laissé la cage de 4 pour le
foot fallait peut-être à la place du top
ten comme ça ou peut-être quatre fautes
et quatre sur m6 d'objets 6 je peux pas
jouer si ça ne marche pas après mais
c'est encore très compliqué parce que
c'est très compliqué complexe métaux
après tour des quatre ça va pas j'ai eu
l'impression que le blanc sont encore
bien sûr je veux mon après 4 je peux
jouer dans bessette aussi d'un bloc mais
pièce que pour continuer la tac avec les
blancs c'est pas pas si fascinant c'est
peu donc c'est simplement une position
peuple est d'accord donc on va revenir
la partie donc après tour des quatre
voies la tour des 27 avait déjà mieux
pour les mains s'était jamais pour les
noirs des fous des trois monts cavalli à
17 donc foot est roi
alors l'idée de foot est roi je pense
pour eux laurent notamment c'est que si
les noirs juifs sicilia d'alger 6 ouais
mais bon qui oblige les non pas je vais
pas laisser d'accord d'idées tu l'avais
vu ballon je me fais maths est donc
d'accord mais par contre ici il ya
d'autres idées pour les noirs c'est
justement que cavalier ses 5es et après
ap six pour prendre le fou puisque sur
d'algeciras cavaliers prendre des trois
d'accord mais je n'ai pas fait tout de
suite à cause de cavaliers à 4 je crois
même meilleur ça va ressembler la partie
d'ailleurs ici il ya plusieurs
possibilités pour les noirs donc soit
soin de faire comme j'ai fait soit de
prendre le pouls sur cinq jouer cavalier
prend et 5 respect c'est toi qui vas les
provinces en rester là les noirs ou
blancs rennais fou 17 17
et après deux mètres la tour sur la
colonne c ou b joue f-18 et essayer
d'attaquer comme ça mais bon j'ai
préféré j'ai préféré l'autre comme
d'accord c'était peut-être possible mais
je préfère jouer je sais ce qu'est la
doublette donc c'était c'était pas clair
donc j'ai préféré le football c'est de
continuer à développer les pièces
d'accord dame g4 bon bah c'est un coup
je sais pas les blancs avait pas grand
chose à faire donc une dame j'ai quatre
cavaliers c5
je sais pas c'était peut-être mieux de
journée laurent frayssinet dans le
public laïque qui rigole sur les
commentaires alors donc cavalier csn
maintenant donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
jouer et 6 et d'échangé le foot est roi
ça ouais comme ça il ya plus des dames
chez sis dont tu me l'as celle ci
complètement gagné on parlera donc il ya
cavaliers à quatre c'est le seul coup
d'accord car il comprend foudre pour
vents et ici j'ai commencé à mal joué
j'ai joué six mois si ça va food et 4
vous des 4 et d'un bep quatre là c'est
pas bien je ne sais pas exactement j'ai
pas trop analysé après la partie mais je
pense qu'il y avait d'autres moyens
peut-être cinq directement d'accord
pourquoi pas 5 puis on prend puis on
prend fous ces cinq dames c'est cette
d'accord oui c'était une possibilité
avec d'audience intro très fort après
qui notamment de son passé d'ailleurs ou
bien phu c6 d'abord mesdames b4 et c'est
pas sebastian d'accord les blancs des
contres chance mais il devrait y avoir
un moyen pour prendre un avantage de
noir alors cavaliers ont biaisé 6 bon
c'est le seul coup pour adé 8 aura des 8
ha non il y avait une autre possibilité
à bhl place de cabaye et b6 a juste de
quoi bon jusqu'au coup avant il y avait
photographié ce qui était possible mais
c'est en reprend ici savelli des tours
j'ai 3 sets à 1 voilà donc je dois
prendre le cavalier d'un point 41.4 j'ai
trois dames 200 m dames 17 même des cmj
et 6 mais bon moi j'ai huit dames 3,6
soit des cats soit de 9,7 et c'est
finalement les duels et blanc ne peuvent
pas maté quoi donc
donc ça ça les dons cavaliers b6 voilà
c'était fort c'était une petite variante
d'accord il faillit
toujours faire attention au noir ne pas
se faire prendre faut prendre 6 oui
d'accord a je crois qu'on l'a on a perdu
leur revient voilà ça revient donc
donc voilà on va revenir la position
donc fallu faire attention effectivement
donc à fou prend m6 d'ambassadeur
variante puisque la tour des trois pôles
et angers 3 et menacé un matin j'ai vite
ses seins donc abc la vie autour des 8 à
3 à 3 donc cela faut faire attention
encore une fois faux problème si ceci
ouais mais c'est pas possible parce que
lecavalier b6 et en prix seront
comprises toujours d'accord dame 10,6
pour ces 3 voilà peut-être qu'à ce
moment là il a joué ça très vite lancé 3
mais peut-être que je sais pas si tour
un tour un possible tournant a eu cinq
tours trois points ici e5 peut-être
c'est pas possible tu peux tourner au 3e
tour le pion et bicloo et puisque la
toile a donc je dois prendre quand même
je dois essayer de prendre way to
reprend maintenant d'un pro b 6 mais ici
il y avait quelque chose comme d'alger
six dames g6 est bon il faut autre chose
est d'accord pour un set
d'accord ouais mais tours 1-7 ya tout
reprend huit tours prend 1,8 et d'amd 6
à huy donc oui maintenant aux menaces
dans le 3e set mais pas d'en prendre
vite là bas encore maintenant et
maintenant c'est ici et surtout ses six
pouces et 6 il y avait simplement damev
sait tous que je sais plus où peut
peut-être qu'il ya d'autres choses aussi
voyant derrière cette dame f7 et six
animateurs saigner le voilà ou peut-être
même mieux pour les blancs donc c'était
il fallait regarder tour 3 à mon avis et
je pense pas que cinq étaient possibles
est bon je sais pas ce qui se serait
passé donc pour ces trois peut-être une
âme et une précision de leur ton ami
donc ça y est la majorité des pions s'en
trouva va débouler phocéens qui n'ont
maintenant j'ai donné j'ai sacrifié la
dame alors ça ça c'est sans peur et sans
reproche ou non mais je pense que de
toute façon je risque rien puisque j'ai
un bon centre mais puis elles sont bien
placés je vais avoir tours tours et le
tour est faux
tours faux espions toit plat dame mais
pour la dame plus faucon de cavaliers
donc vers de faux et tout revient place
et donc qui est bon et on va peut-être
pas regarder mais il y avait peut-être
des possibilités pour jouer f prend 1,5
à certains moments d'accord on m'a parlé
de la ville parce que tant d'autres
voies on va voir la suite alors c'est
intéressant donc ce moment-là ce
sacrifice dame est permis de récupérer
le plomb f4 quand même voilà européen
revient 24 donc ici je pense que les
noirs sont nettement mieux mais le
problème at-elle catia v4 des quatre
cavaliers c5 et cavaliers detroit et je
sais pas exactement comment père c'est
donc j'ai préféré garder les pions
l'idée notamment le cuir passer de dieu
qui est passé maître la faune tu n'as
pas ton frère faut calmer le calme elle
place le cavalier en d3 et je sais pas
si l'accord l'on va on va continuer
maintenant sur la fin de cette partie de
calais nord est en gros avantage
notamment centrale avec les pions qui
menaçait d'aller à dame c'est depuis la
fin c'était assez facile puisque en plus
laurent n'étais pas très motivé
vous voyez pendant la partie donc ils
étaient ils pensaient déjà que c'était
perdu c'est ça ouais d'accord on va dire
mais on va dérouler rapidement on voit
que les pions noirs bon ça voilà donc à
ce moment-là je pensais que c'était
c'était complètement fini mais j'ai pas
je vais peut-être pas beaucoup de temps
et j'ai laissé omettre le cavalier en d3
oui donc j'ai laissé quelque chose pour
l'instant ce cavalier l'étions c'est ça
finalement
il veut bien et bien passé mais
maintenant la tour est complètement jeu
la tourache 3 et là il ya soit 4,4 au
cas pour éliminer le cavalier nombre
pour contrôler le plus de casse possible
d'accord la tour eiffe trois mois c'est
la dernière heure mais c'est vrai
qu'après damage synchro à j 7
je ne sais pas s'il y avait des vraies
possibilités de sauvetage
mais bon après tout répit trois reprises
prise d'empreintes
tours 6 coutu normalement puisque bon
ici laurent il a joué je sais plus
d'alger kajima et c'est le plus en plus
il fallait jouer damage 5
il fallait essayer damage 5 avant de
toute façon m 5
oui de toute façon je joue f5 d'un point
f5 et tour des 8es il ya plus d'échecs
d'accord il est le pion au passé si ça
va se retrouver dans une finale avec
deux tours est fou contre dame des
contres dames et d'options mais bon ça
devrait gagner facilement d'une sucrerie
sommes d'accord cavaliers c'est un
week-end relier ces 1 c'était possible
ce colloque est donc ça veut dire je
trouve ça veut dire que laurent a
peut-être raté des façons de nommer ici
c'est très bon ça doit être possible
exposés me donnait marché pas le
conservant ses qualités de dos ne marche
pas parce qu'il y aurait carrément les
rangs et s'ils gagnent le foot c'est ça
ouais d'accord donc volé cegeka volume 2
de sacrifier toujours le cavalier donc
les rovers on va s'arrêter là sur cette
partie dont ça ça démontre en tout cas
peut-être
plus facilement compromis airs à bord
puisque on avait l'impression que les
blancs afin que les noirs avaient gagné
relativement facilement que les enfin
après après les pions noirs est avancée
au centre que d'un saut nationale est en
général pour gagner une partie d'échecs
à ce niveau là faut vraiment se battre
sur tous les coups c'est jallet et
c'était difficile nouvelle a montré la
note est théorique elle est obligée son
adversaire du jeu et cette partie le jeu
passe et riante avec les blancs donc il
ya là beaucoup d'axés aspects de n'est
pas été prêt pour ce combat
en tout cas alors bravo encore etienne
bacrot donc champion de france 2000 pour
la deuxième année donc consécutive
donc ça ne sais pas s'il ya un courrier
ont peut-être un record à battre non non
champion de france consécutif à l'étagé
le temps d'accord c'est pas pour
maintenant
merci aussi dorfman aussi vice-champion
de france pour pour cette année aussi
on va maintenant recevoir et loire lange
qui a lui même joué le tournoi et qui va
nous présenter la liste de tous les de
tous les participants
je crois qu'on va pas rater un seul sauf
peut-être igor nataf qui n'a pas pu nous
rejoindre et on va donc recevoir tous
les joueurs et encore paquereau était
pas bravo pardon bravo a été de
maquereaux il croyait le public ici vous
pouvez vous applaudir le champion de
france je passe le micro à eloi merci
stéphane donc bonjour à tous donc là
ensemble on va regarder un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé mis à part nos deux
nos deux premiers puisqu'il son premier
détaché apparemment inoffensifs dorfman
ne sera pas rattrapé ou alors peut-être
par arnaud hauchard qui est encore en
train de jouer contre eux christian
bauer et qui peut gagner donc cette
dernière partie puisqu'il va
retournement de situation complètement
incroyable en attendant la fin de cette
partie on accueille pour l'instant le
troisième temporaire puisqu'il reste une
partie c'est jean-marc degraeve qui est
à ma gauche bonsoir jean marc émond soir
et un autre jeune star de dax le jeune
laurent frayssinet bonsoir laurent
manceau eloi laurent donc qui termine
apparemment 7e donc on va commencer en
continuant sur la lancée avec jean-marc
donc là tu réalises 6 points et demi tu
gagne 7 points elo une performance à
presque 2006 satisfait de cet endroit
oui globalement satisfait mon essai la
partie d'hier j'ai perdu bêtement contre
les aussies dorfman qui est un peu enfin
bon j'ai refusé la lune et après mon
j'ai perdu bêtement
oui alors on a commenté hier donc
évidemment vous pouvez revenir dans les
archives de diagonale pour la pour la
revoir donc une défaite à l'avant
dernière ronde alors que tu avais tu été
l'auteur d'une très belle série puisque
tu a enchaîné trois victoires d'affilée
contre une belle dépose adversaires oui
oui là j'étais assez content moi j'ai un
peu premier à jouer soit floue mais bon
quand christian la partie j'ai eu un peu
de chance
oui la fameuse partie que jean marc
andreu christian bauer avec une position
assez délicate tuner habituellement en
championnat de france
tu ne réussis pas très bien pourquoi
enfin là c'est en tout cas c'est une
année exceptionnelle puisque troisième
c'est une des meilleures places en
championnat de france
oui j'avais fini deuxièmes ex-aequo à
toulouse en dirigeant 16 en 96 et donc
après oui j'ai très mal joué pourquoi je
sais pas c'était peut-être dans la tête
maintenant ça va très bien quoi
d'accord donc en tout cas très belle
performance 6 points et demi alors le
zonal c'est sûr tu vas participer
automnale qui commence
donc dans trois jours ou quatre jours
qui se déroule en espagne à côté du
portugal
oui c'est ça et ça va être un peu dur
parce qu'on est déjà assez fatigué non
il faut rejouer 11 parties dans quatre
jours des parties contre des très forts
joueurs donc ça va être vraiment
difficile quoi et alors possibilité
aussi pour les olympiades
c'est à dire qu'on prend les trois
premiers du championnat rappelons le
donc ici à des places qualificatives
si arnaud hauchard gagne il aura sept
points puisque pour l'instant il est
encore en train de jouer c'est ça la
magie du direct il aura sept points et
donc à ce moment là ça sera les trois
qualifiés mais en revanche en cas de nul
ou de défaite toujours un match de
départage demain avec tristan bauer ou
arnaud chat oui oui c'est certain genre
à un petit match mais ça sera mal en
point devant un public nombreux
c'est toujours intéressant oui alors
c'est rappelons quand même que la salle
du national on a vu des images mais ça
se passe dans un grande grand auditorium
avec beaucoup de public potentiel donc
effectivement pour des matchs deux
parties semi-rapides c'est toujours très
attractif donc jean-marc bravo pour
cette troisième place actuellement qui
n'est quand même pas une
contre-performance qui est plutôt bien
et maintenant je me tourne à ma droite
le jeune laurent frayssinet donc laurent
tu étais plutôt bien parti et tu as fait
une série de défaites
oui j'ai fait un bruit sur 4 donc entre
les deux dernières de la première poule
les deux dernières parties de la
première pole et les deux premières de
la poule haute donc c'est vrai que j'ai
perdu j'ai perdu toute chance de
remporter le titre surtout face à
etienne où j'avais seulement et demi
point de retard et en plus vu que la
partie qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
donc j'ai perdu cette partie et après
c'est vrai que c'était c'était quand
même fini pour le titre est même pour
les places d'honneur ça devient très dur
très dur donc tu n'a que 18 ans c'est la
troisième participation au championnat
de france si je ne fais pas d'erreur et
c'est de mieux en mieux ou tu as fait
tes meilleures performances que ça
disons que l'année dernière j'avais
j'avais quand même beaucoup mieux joué
mais bon disons que c'est les années
j'ai fini que 7e l'année dernière mais
j'avais fait 5 sur 7 dans la première
poule et j'avais perdu ce n'est pas la
même formule disons qu'il y avait les
demi finales
il fallait dans les deux premiers pour
se qualifier donc j'étais 2e ex-aequo
avec etienne bacrot j'ai perdu le fameux
match contre etienne et donc j'avais pas
mais dix ans après et j'avais encore
bien joué j'avais réalisé normes de vent
m donc j'ai bien joué j'ai mieux joué
que cette année oui le fameux match on
s'en rappelle tous c'était l'année
dernière devant une salle complètement
comble de 700 personnes donc laurent
frayssinet contre etienne bacrot un
match marathon avec un partout un
partout un partout nouvelle égalité
blitz de départage
c'était vraiment du grand spectacle au
niveau des formules peut être un petit
mot donc alors rappelons que la première
formule c'était quand le tournoi fermé
où les quinze joueurs jouer tous les uns
contre les autres
seize joueurs même la formule suivante
c'était les deux premiers de chaque
poule joue des matches à élimination
directe et cette année les quatre
premiers de chaque poule rencontre les
quatre ans et de l'autre poule
enfin cette année c'est un système
hybride donc une préférence pour un des
systèmes alors jean marc peut-être moi
je préfère une tout rond toutes rondes
et laurent moi je pense que le tout rend
n'est plus équitable mais disons pour le
public c'est que c'était un peu un peu
lassant vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
nuls de salanque m
faux faut le reconnaître est donc parce
que les joueurs étaient fatigués et donc
c'est vrai que 15e rang de ses plus
équitable mais c'est beaucoup plus
fatigant et donc finalement moi je
préfère les systèmes peut-être comme
l'année dernière le système l'année
dernière était assez bon chemin
donc le système à élimination directe en
tout cas qualification élimination
effectivement iossif dorfman etienne
bacrot préfère le 15e ronde enfin le
tout ronde
jean-marc degraeve aussi donc chacun son
avis laurent frayssinet voit le public
et ça on peut le féliciter
alors laurent ce tournoi quelques mots
encore la qualité tu es parti est ce que
est ce que tu étais en forme puisque tu
es là tu es sur la montante on appelle
la montante
c'est à dire que tu fais que des bonnes
performances tu a enchaîné les normes de
grand maître tu vas être bientôt grand
maître au prochain congrès de la fidh
est donc ici satisfait de cette
prestation mais pas du tout c'est clair
que le niveau de mes parties étaient
disons que les
et en plus même quand j'avais trois
nuits sur cinq au début j'ai fait nul
contre lui aussi faisait man avant
j'étais complètement perdu quand robert
fontaine pareil donc j'ai un peu de
chance mais et puis après j'ai pas
réussi à élever le niveau de mon jeu
donc j'ai vraiment très bien joué dans
l'ensemble très mal joué bon et bien
mettons ça sur le compte je ne sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs oui pourquoi tu
travailles jouer et j'en sais rien je
vais essayer de tirer les conclusions de
ce tournant d'accord donc tu conserve
des chances d'aller en équipe de france
et éventuellement zonal en cas de
désistement puisqu'on sait que les
places ne sont pas redescendus donc en
tout cas si tu y participes ça sera
intéressant à suivre
un dernier petit mot vous avez joué
entre vous avez joué tous les deux je
crois que jean marc a gagné un petit mot
sur la partie si oui je les joue au bon
moment je pense que vous venez juste de
perdre contre etienne donc en fait j'ai
joué le lendemain il était peut-être les
jeunes et motivés pour le titre de
champion tandis que moi j'avais
justement gagné quand christian non
comme moi c'était contraire et donc je
pense que ça s'est plutôt jour moral
laurent tu es d'accord avec cette
analyse
oui je sais pas je ne suis pas trop en
du monde mais disons qu'il a il a bien
joué il est bien mené son affaire et
c'est vrai que j'étais pas trop je
venais de faire un ennemi sur trois donc
c'était ma mauvaise série et donc il m'a
vu il m'a pris au bon moment et en plus
il a mieux joué donc il n'y a rien à
dire
d'accord bon eh bien messieurs je vous
remercie je félicitations encore en tout
cas jean marc laurent tu fera mieux la
prochaine fois je l'espère nous
l'espérons tous et bien je vais donc
passer à une nouvelle série d'invités si
on peut envoyer les deux suivants qui
vont nous faire part de leur tournoi
donc merci et bravo encore
alors nous accueillons jean-rené corps
la surprise du tournoi et à ma droite
anatolie weisser vainqueur ex-aequo de
la poule basse donc on va commencer par
jean rené j'en ai qui a la particularité
d'être le seul joueur non professionnels
ou en tout cas un des sols non
professionnels de ce tournoi est en tout
cas le seul joueur qui ne soit pas 100%
disponible pour les échecs qu'ils aient
réussi à se qualifier en poule haute
alors je reconnais quel est ton secret
secret il n'y en a pas tellement et je
pense que avec le peu de temps dont je
dispose je vais directement à
l'essentiel et j'arrive à 10 ans à vivre
un peu sont mes acquis c'est vrai que
c'est une situation un peu difficile je
fais pas autant de choses que je
voudrais pour les échecs ça se ressent
au niveau de mon jeu notamment au niveau
de la préparation dans les ouvertures
qui demande beaucoup de travail mais bon
j'ai compris que les ouvertures
n'étaient pas tous que le niveau de jeu
général c'est quand même le plus
important et donc je m'appuie là dessus
donc ici quand même cinq points et demi
une performance à 2527 c'est quand même
une très très belle performance et on a
vu que tu as réussi à tenir donc donc
contrôler iossif dorfman par exemple bon
tu moi je trouve que c'est en tout cas
une excellente prestation puisque c'est
papa dit enfin c'est très très difficile
donc la question est la suivante combien
de temps tu t'entraînes et comment faire
pour arriver en forme dans un tournoi
comme ça un tournoi aussi forte le
meilleur tournoi avec enfin avec les
meilleurs joueurs français
comment comment faire pour tenir je ne
sais pas s'il suffit de vivre sur ses
acquis pour pour aussi un facteur france
comme ça je m'entraîne très très peu ça
doit être en moyenne de 2 heures par
semaine à peu près
quand j'ai l'occasion de jouer que ce
soit en équipe ou championnat de france
je leur fais plus évidemment
donc j'essaye de quand je fais un peu
des chaînes j'essaye d'aller directement
au plus important
et puis je pense que c'est important
d'arriver avec beaucoup d'énergie
on se rend compte que les partis il ya
des retournements de situations souvent
il faut être bien physiquement et donc
là le championnat de france en août me
réussit en général bien parce que j'ai
l'occasion de me reposer un petit peu
avant et j'arrive avec pas mal de une
grosse envie de jouer et pas mal
d'énergie d'accord donc bon et bien en
tout cas bon résultat cinq points et
demi c'est pas mal il ya une contre
performance à ma droite donc après la
performance
la contre-performance du tournoi je
pense que qu'on peut le dire anatolie
weisser donc en ampoule basse c'est une
surprise puisque avec un lots de 2537
bas vous faisait office de favori en
fait tout simplement enfin deux joueurs
prêts à se qualifier alors que s'est il
passé
le challenge pour moi fort alors
problèmes de chaleur et avec l'âge ceux
qui viennent puiser plus importants et
vers 7h beetle 2 soir j'étais presque
sans cerveau je jouais sur l'autre
pilote et des fois elle en tout cas je
n'ai pas gagné 3 positionne avec des
drames davantage
je pense gagnante et ça c'était dans les
phases préliminaires alors ça suffit
gagner une ou deux c'était bien
alors donc tu avais été champion de
france en 1997 quand même si comme
dernières sont exactes donc ici c'est le
manque d'entraînement puisqu'on sait que
tu ne t'entraînes tu n'es plus
complètement disponible pour les échecs
puisque je crois que tu a dérivé vers le
milieu de la finance
oui maintenant je joue aux échecs en
trois dimensions parce que c'est une
jolie métaphore pour dire la bourse
et bien sûr je sais beaucoup moins
disponibles mais cette année j'ai mis
une semaine entière en transforme et bon
peut-être s'était passé où je suis
l'aîné prochaine si josiane l'été je
serai au moins deux semaines
donc voilà en tout cas la surprise vient
quand même du résultat final puisque on
sait que tu es un joueur très très
combatif extrêmement combatif qui donne
tout quittera qui est à l'énergie qui
est à fond et ici quand on voit le
résultat final je vois une seule
victoire alors
comment ça de suite attention deux
victoires tout à fait autant pour moi la
grille fait donc oui la grille est plus
grande que prévu donc deux victoires
mais c'est quand même pas beaucoup
1 seule défaite une seule défaite
j'ai expliqué que sur le jeu parce que
si première partie je trois positions
gagnant est bon je dis que au bout de
certains nombre d'heures sur la scène
les scènes c'était très très chaud et
tout femme et moi je ne rêvais pas
réfléchi bon ça c'est mon problème mais
sinon l'organisation était magnifique
c'était un seul bémol c'est vrai que
c'est souvent le problème en plein mois
d'août de réussir à avoir une salle un
peu fraîche
oui ça c'est c'est clairement un
problème donc peut-être le manque de
pratique qui a fait qu'on a que tu n'as
pas réaliser les positions en tout cas à
nathalie vasseur donc premier de la
poule basse six points sur 11 et
performances à 2523 ce n'est pas
forcément bon enfin c'est pas c'est
parce qu'on attendait on attendait
peut-être une surprise mais ce n'est pas
arrivé
alors un petit mot sur les formules
puisque c'est devenu une question
traditionnelle 15 rondes élimination
après les qualifications par deux ou
alors tout l'autre poule basse une
préférence peut-être genre des corps
avant de répondre je voulais
faire une remarque par rapport à ce que
tu as dit on attendait certainement un
atelier en poule haute
mais il faut remarquer que dans chaque
poule il ya au moins cinq ou six joueurs
qu'ils étaient capables a priori d'aller
en poule haute
et mathématiquement certains doivent
passer à la trappe et donc forcément des
joueurs qu'on attendait en poule haute
ce retour en poule basse mais c'est vrai
que
le ça montre que le tournoi est de plus
en plus fort alors concernant la formule
à titre personnel je préfère les 11
rondes pour des pros des raisons pour
des raisons de disponibilité
bon c'est vrai que pour moi c'est plus
facile de jouer 11 rondes que 15 je
pense pas que le tournoi à 15 secondes
soit plus intéressant parce que
forcément on n'a pas la même énergie sur
15 rondes plus sur 11 et enfin sur la
justice sportive
j'ai l'impression que quelle que soit la
formule le meilleur doit l'emporter
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
l'inconvénient de cette de cette formule
c'est de faire deux groupes après cette
ronde souvent ceux qui sont en milieu de
classement ça se joue à très peu et donc
pour les joueurs qui se retrouvent
malheureusement en poule basse
le tournoi est peut-être moins
intéressant par la suite mais on a
remarqué quand même que
même les joueurs en poule basse ont mis
un point d'honneur à tenir leur rang 1
pour remporter ce mini-tournoi donc les
craintes à ce sujet sont peut-être pas
justifié d'accord donc la formule de
cette année a l'air bon j'espère oui
d'accord anatolie chaque formule et à
ses défauts et je pense une seule est
moins dur à accepter pour les autres
c'est aux rondes mais douze joueurs wii
alors effectivement ça obligerait quand
même à ne pas qualifier quatre joueurs
oui oui parce que à l'époque
à quoi ça servait jouer ses joueurs l
époque on n'avait pas de outre peu de
grain m en france alors s'adonner double
norme
maintenant on a dépassé les limites
maintenant on a autant de grenet que
c'est très facile de voir normes partout
et séries16 joël si quand même peut-être
que ça allait se passer des jeunes non
il ya on voit l'apparition notamment de
joueurs de l'accession du champion de
france junior on laisse un peu la chance
aux jeunes plutôt que de laisser les
vieux routiers
mettant nos places de place l'accession
et encore du joueur sélectionné ça va
bon ce sera un peu donc la formule
proposée par anatolie n'existe pas
encore mais en tout cas on l'a proposera
effectivement donc ça serait la formule
qui plairait plus douze joueurs 11
rondes et on en parle plus si on me
demande 16 joueurs
jouer pendant deux semaines et demie ou
bien les formules aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est plus dynamique même si
moi j'étais malheureux mais mieux bon on
ne sait pas on n'a pas encore assez
on va voir des défauts si on essaie mais
ce que j'ai entendu ici le point à mon
allée d'accord moins bien donc rappelons
quand même les résultats genre décor
huitième du tournoi avec enfin 6e
ex-aequo 7e ex-aequo 7e ex-aequo grand
fois ci ça dépend encore du résultat
christian bauer qui peut perdre toujours
je peux encore arrivé à 6e si christian
pers voilà souhaite pas donc en tout cas
ni olympiades nini zonal en sixième des
raisons de disponibilité sinon je serais
les automnales avec plaisir oui mais je
vais jouer aussi la coupe d'europe avec
mon club c'est vous qui sera
probablement un tournoi très intéressant
puisque mon président m'a promis
premiers échiquiers d'accord donc le la
vie de club la vie de joueur de club
donc le club de genre n'est qu'au club
de mulhouse vallée en coupe d'europe
très intéressant donc ça c'est les
projets un atelier walser premier de la
poule basse donc 9e ex-aequo avec
manuela puis c'est la méga aux sounders
berger le nom barbare du système de
départage voilà donc je pense également
qu'on peut applaudir nos deux joueurs et
on va passer à deux suivants voilà donc
nous allons accueillir maintenant robert
fontaine
à ma gauche et manuela pis c'est là à ma
droite donc là nous sommes dans la poule
basse nous y sommes de plain pied
puisque vous avez trois joueurs de la
poule basse sur le plateau manuel a
pissé la ex-aequo avec un zoli weiser
six points +3 points elo performance à
2626 donc
bonne bon résultat nous bons résultats
d'ensemble mais j'aurais préféré dans la
poule haute
pour faire entendre un plus intéressant
et et enfin rencontré etienne bacrot
embarquée longue ça n'est pas arrivé en
gare donc aux arrivées pas arrivé donc
rappelons donc tu es de la génération à
peu près de la même génération spontanée
où on a eu tous les meilleurs juniors je
pense que ça doit être jean-luc chavanon
jean-marc de grève arnaud hauchard
jorunée corps genre en écosse je veux un
petit peu plus vieux cloutier mais trois
ans d'écart quoi oui donc ça nous direz
c'est la même génération aussi donc tu
continue encore à jouer ce à jouer ce
national donc tu te considère vraiment
comme un joueur d'échecs actifs ou est
ce que tu aimes bien un petit bémol sur
ta carrière de joueur d'échecs
je joue un peu moins ces derniers temps
ben may
dans l'ensemble quand même je fais
encore des tournois ça m'arrive de me
déplacer à l'étranger pour faire des
fortes endroit donc c'est vrai que je
perds un joueur très active mais vous
dire quand même je suis un joueur actif
un joueur semi actif actif qui est qui
est ici positionnelle positionnelle le
haut niveau technique les parties
comment se sont elles passées tu as tu
as pu laisser s'exprimer ton style je
vois deux victoires une perte et que des
nuls beaucoup de nuls os x devrait
m'aider nul accroché souvent quelques
quelques parties avantageuse que j'ai
pas réussi à gagner ici est bon dans
l'ensemble où je n'étais pas mauvais que
ça allait à peu près je regrette qu'une
seule partie en fait c'est justement la
dernière partie de la septième ronde en
fait pour si je veux gagner cette partie
j'étais en poule haute il la fameuse
sept mondes iossif dorfman en parlais
tout à l'heure
effectivement il ya toujours un enjeu
être en poule haute est en boule passe
en fait la tension nerveuse et est
toujours requise
une plante y certainement gagner on
d'ailleurs certainement contre genre en
écosse donc effectivement après après ne
pas avoir gagné ça il ya une certaine
démotivation qui doit s'installer
puisqu'on se retrouve en poule basse au
lieu de la poule haute on ne peut plus
jouer pour le titre de champion de
france après la seule motivation c'était
gagné les poules le pass la seule
motivation c'est gagné la foule base
dont qui a été réalisé donc manuela fils
et la championne 3,92
on va revenir tout à l'heure d'abord
quelques questions au champion de france
juniors 2000 robert fontaine bonjour
alors
performances dans le temps à perte à la
dernière ronde ça c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle et sinon comment as-tu donc on
va on va donner exactement ce qui s'est
passé cinq points gain de points elo
performance à 2459 donc a priori une
performance prévu puisque c'est une
performance atone lots satisfait mais
pas trop et c'est un peu de sens enfin
c'est toujours un peu décevant de perdre
une dernière ronde quoi surtout vu
comment je les ai perdus donc bon
j'aurais pu espérer avoir un meilleur
résultat mais alors la question c'est
donc tu est un jeune joueur d'échecs tu
as probablement vite devenir joueur
professionnel mais je sais pas j'ai
passé mon bac cette année
donc maintenant je vais quand même
essayer un hand
je voulais essayer ans de
professionnalisme échec bon finalement
je vais quand même continuer un peu les
études et si les échecs ça marche bien
je vais je vais quand même essayer de
devenir professionnel
mais pour l'instant je j'essaie de
concilier de quoi d'accord donc après
manuel qui est semi actif tué semi
professionnel tout à fait d'accord alors
comment t'es-tu entraîné pour le pour le
tournoi de foot a fait une préparation
spéciale avant de venir ici puisque en
août s'est apparemment les grandes
vacances non agression s'est nommé chez
j'ai regardé quand même les partis d des
joueurs de la poule et mais après on
sait très difficile de se préparer vu
qu'on ne connaît pas les joueurs de la
poule basse et haute
donc petite préparation mais papa énorme
quoi d'accord donc bon alors donc pas
satisfait effectivement les jeunes aux
dents longues en veulent toujours plus
donc tu reviendras l'année prochaine oui
j'espère d'accord et espérons le à leur
bon maintenant question devenue
traditionnelle la formule 1 manuel est
bien dans l'ensemble j'aime bien les
tournois toute ronde quand même il tord
à tout rond ce qui était bien dans le
ton - 15 parties c'est quand il y avait
deux jours de repos parce que sinon
c'est vraiment trop fatigant donc on
jouait sein des tranches de cinq par
tirer qu'une journée de repos au milieu
mais
mais le fait de jouer on ce parti c'est
quand même c'est quand même une bonne
idée aussi oui donc effectivement la
formule ce qui serait intéressant ce
serait on ce parti avec ses joueurs mais
un toute ronde 101 en laissant quelques
parties dont john et robert
les formules donnez moi moi je préfère
la formule toute ronde quoi à 16 joueurs
et 15 parties cop comme ça on peut voir
un vrai manque yen qui est le meilleur
quoi parce que voilà non nous joue des
gens dans la poule basse mais les poules
sont pas forcément équilibré dès le
départ donc voilà c'est pas je pense que
c'est pas optimal d'accord donc
effectivement disponibilité maximum 15
secondes
effectivement deux jours de repos ça
c'est vrai c'est pour les joueurs
professionnels c'est mieux c'est
l'ancien système qu'on avait en union
soviétique les fameux tournoi marathon
qui durait jusqu'à un mois deux mois
puisque on faisait des 15 joueurs enfin
16 joueurs double ronde ou quadruples
ronde donc ça dure est vraiment très
très longtemps
plus les jours normaux c'est un jour de
repos c'était complètement complètement
extrême du sport extrême
ces joueurs coin de rue claude ça c'est
juste ça s'est vu en union soviétique
voilà voilà pour les pour les formules
donc manuela pis elle a pas tout à fait
satisfait mais pas complètement déçu non
plus on sauve un certain temps dans un
moyen quoi donc le lien retour l'année
prochaine
oui retour l'année prochaine robert
fontaine pas très bien oui mais tant pis
mais tant pis au niveau des normes de
grands maîtres le titre se précise mais
j'en ai une et il nous faut encore deux
mais je joue pas mal de tournois
intéressants donc j'espère en avoir
encore une oeuvre la fin de l'année quoi
d'accord et bien on te souhaite une très
bonne année semi sabbatique
merci manuel merci et très bonne
continuation donc espérons que national
reviendra à sa formule d'antan merci
messieurs on peut encore les applaudir
et alors nous accueillons d'arcoa
nietzsche bonsoir darko et guillaume
valent un bon soir guillaume donc deux
joueurs encore de la poule basse
puisqu'on nous approchons de la fin
darko alors performance à 2456 -4 points
elo cinq points donc troisièmes ex-aequo
de la poule basse oui cette annonce
n'était pas le résultat que j'espérais
en tout cas je très mal démarré au début
donc c'était trop tard pour
effectivement il me faut un peu de temps
pour le procès chauffer j'ai commencé à
jouer beaucoup mieux vers la fin de
tournoi alors je crois que tu te
consacres beaucoup à l'entraînement
problèmes des jeunes et ça va te prendre
beaucoup d'énergie oui je dirigeais
c'est le cavalier bleu pour les donc une
école d échec
effectivement je passe mon temps
à l'entraîneur de les autres pour moi
même donc une préparation spéciale pour
ce tournoi de pas spécialement mais
faudel que je suis tout le temps dans
les échecs donc ça compte aussi beaucoup
donc alors une fois de plus nous avons
nous accueillons darko donkey qui
l'année dernière a fait le score
complètement explosif de six points sur
7 dans les qualifications qui s'est
retrouvé propulsé est très très loin
devant dans la poule donc six points sur
cette requête une performance
exceptionnelle et ensuite donc dans les
fameuses phase finale tu as perdu les
deux matches si je crois si je me
rappelle bien contre etienne bacrot
christian navet jets peuvent de
l'apprendre le premier match contre
tiennent à l'atteindre chances dans la
première partie et deuxième match donc
j'ai joué j'ai peur d'eux dans la somme
et rapide
donc je jouais 1 1 avec christian donc
ici cette année ce n'était pas pas une
bonne année
en tout cas tu n'as jamais été vraiment
opposition de
de faire quelque chose d'exceptionnel ne
serait ce que 2 se qualifiant pour
l'autre puisque tu je crois que tu as
très mal démarré
alors pourquoi est ce que les positions
parce que les pressions avec eux tu
allais avait l'air très bonne mais elle
avait été bonne elle était bonne mais
pour il fallait il fallait peut-être un
petit peu plus de concentration
donc là j'ai raté dans le gain contre
david nationaux jeune j'avais une partie
tout le monde est contre toi donc c'est
trop tard pour agir pour se rattraper
d'accord donc un manque de pratique ou
ou alors un manque de concentration
oui peut-être un peu de tout parce que
j'ai pas beaucoup joué cette année mais
je pense que maintenant je commence je
me sens beaucoup mieux alors c'est vrai
que en général on commence à se chauffer
vers la fin et on est toujours déçu que
le tournoi s'arrête poteau je peins
parfois en baisse de forme ski
affecté main certainement au canada
l'année dernière il a tu fais les deux
les deux extrêmes on fait alors à ma
droite donc dire mme vallin venu
directement de l'accession bonsoir j'ai
remporté la déco avec leur guitare et
lee qui va passer plus tard
l'accession l'année dernière donc on a
eu en fait une sorte de passe droit pour
le jouer le national cette année
alors donc tu est classé 2399 tu as fait
trois points et demi donc tu perds cinq
points elo et je crois que tu es très
jeune puisque tu n'a que 19 ans où j'ai
19 ans 19 ans donc bon tu fais partie de
la nouvelle génération tu as joué le
chant théâtre en juniors avec robert
fontaine cette année oui j'ai terminé
deuxième juste derrière lui juste
derrière lui donc là vous êtes retrouvé
une fois de plus ici est ce que tu es
satisfait de sa presse de cette
prestation en tout cas c'était un peu
une découverte du haut niveau enfin du
haut niveau français en tout cas oui bah
j'ai en fait j'ai jamais joué un tournoi
équivalent à celui ci je n'ai jamais
joué autant dehors mètres à la fois on
perdre uniquement 5 points et l'os et je
pense que c'est une bonne performance
mais je suis surtout content des deux
victoires que j'ai fait dans ce tournoi
oui alors ça c'est vrai que donc tu es
un joueur sans compromis puisque l'on
voit deux gains et alors les défaites il
y en a six donc c'est un peu trop pour
espérer terminer un petit peu plus haut
en tout cas c'est très très combatif
alors bon qu'est-ce que une question
supplémentaire
je ne sais plus je ne sais plus je ne
sais plus bon alors dans la chaussée
plus du tout guillaume va l'inde donc
deuxième des championnats de france de
cette année voilà c'est un peu le
marathon là vous voyez puisque c'est on
est enfin donnée en fin d'émission ici à
vichy c'est direct de diagonale c'est
assez fatigant -5 points elo de gains
bon donc c'est moins globalement je suis
satisfait j'espérais j'espérais
peut-être dont j'aurais pu tirer les
points supplémentaires parfois par
exemple contre jean rené j'avais une
position supérieure contre christian
bauer j'ai voulu forcer le gain alors
que c'était nul
mais bon c'est l'expérience qui rentre
en fait c'est un gros acquise voilà
alors ça y est c'est revenu puisque tu
avais commencé le tournoi avec un point
et demi sur deux donc la honte tout le
monde te voyez comme étant la nouvelle
ils ont un peu la surprise de ce tournoi
et je me rappelle de nocif dorfman à la
troisième ronde petite anecdote qui
venaient voir un peu tous les joueurs
pour dire alors je joue là contre
guillou valin alors ils jouent bien ils
jouent bien
et donc il ya tout ça fait très peur
puisque on a tout ce qui était
extrêmement fort et c'est allé très très
dur et malheureusement donc je crois pas
sympa et tricia j'ai perdu en vain cours
effectivement c'est la fameuse partie
commenté un peu un peu difficile donc
guillaume trois points et demi avant
dernier donc question traditionnelle une
fois de plus la formule dargaud la
première c'était mon meilleur tour
naturland 15 secondes si c'est possible
je sais que financièrement c'est plus
lourd mais une formule comme ça il a
quand même quelques anomalies petites
anomalies on peut dire que même dans la
poule basse on va retrouver le joueur
qui vont avoir le plus de points que
certains dans la poule haute
donc là dans ce sens je vois que il ya
c'est que c'est pas tout à fait voeu la
bonne la bonne il faut peut-être encore
affinés peut-être il faut que tout le
monde se rejoint dans le classement
final
oui on peut quand même constater que
dans la poule où tous les joueurs ont
fait une performance supérieure aux
joies de la poule basse bon alors c'est
effectivement c'est peut-être dans ce
tournoi et on peut envisager des cas de
figure où quatre sur quatre dans la même
base contre 0 sur quatre dans la poule
haute là ça soit plus le cas mais en
tout cas on peut quand même dire que les
joueurs qui sont dans la poule où tu le
méritais vraiment et qui l'ont fait
quand même un excellent tournoi ici
stauffer donc pour cette année je pense
que la formule en tout cas été a été
plutôt bien guillaume moins bon pour une
première expérience
bon je trouve la formule globalement
acceptable par rapport à l'année
dernière je trouve que c'est préférable
parce qu'en fait un narco pourra le dire
il a fait six points sur 7 dans la
première phase mais il avait perdu tout
son bénéfice après il tire il y avait
des demi finales et finale ils étaient à
égalité avec ceux qui avaient fait avec
christian etienne et et david marciano
qui est fait au moins deux points qui
étaient également qualifiés donc cette
année c'est on conserve le nombre de
points acquis lors de la première phase
mais bon sinon je pense que la formule
du tout rond des plus équitables
d'accord bon eh bien je pense qu'on a on
est tous dit une fois de plus c'est
apparemment la formule du tout ronde qui
semble revenir le plus souvent
donc messieurs les joueurs merci je
pense qu'on va
vous remercier on va prendre le dernier
le dernier joueur du tournoi le dernier
restant voilà donc merci d'être venus
encore une fois de plus ces derniers
vont peu les applaudir puisque alors je
vois un doublé puisqu'il y a laurent
guitard a dit à ma droite
bonsoir laurent et le président la
fédération française jean claude
loubatières donc nous allons en finir en
finir entre guillemets avec les joueurs
laurent expérience très difficile donc
tu à 2297 tu fais deux points dans le
tournoi et tu perds cinq points elo
difficile ouais très difficile oui c'est
ta première expérience dans un tournoi
aussi fort ouais ouais c'est la première
fois que je jouais autant de grands
maîtres mais un petit peu comme comme
guillaume qui viennent qui viennent
passer là est bon mais qu'est ce que je
peux dire j'ai pris quand même pas mal
de temps mal d'expérience je pense et
samassa va beaucoup m'apporter fait
j'espère d'accord donc tu va retirer
énormément de ce tournoi il ya des
partis qui t'ont marqué tu n'a
malheureusement pas nier deux parties
est ce que tu as eu des bonnes positions
que t'as pas exploité est ce qu'à un
moment il ya eu un manque de un manque
de pratique mais je pense que j'ai
souvent manqué d'expérience ou quelque
chose comme ça bon contre toi notamment
je pense que c'était quand même assez
facile à gagner dg est par contre j'ai
souvent craqué dans des positions égal
je pense cependant que des spas
d'expérience ou quelque chose comme ça
quoi enchaîner tous les jours des partis
aussi difficile
c'est vraiment très fatiguant que willow
rien n'est fait qu'on retrouve souvent
c'est à dire que les joueurs de
l'accession arrivant dans le national en
général sont les deux plus faibles entre
guillemets du tournoi en tout cas au
classement elo donc tous les joueurs
habitués les joueurs habituels sont là
pour l'heure entre guillemets une fois
leur taper dessus puisque les points
sont tous très difficile à marquer donc
en jaune
quand on joue contre les deux arrivants
on a vraiment envie d'essayer de prendre
les points
et ça c'est très difficile puisque tous
les jours on a un joueur extrêmement
forts qui arrive avec la ferme intention
de gagner et ça s'est pas fait c'est
assez difficile à supporter quoi
en plus les gens sont très bien préparés
tout ça parce qu'on n'a pas des
répertoires aussi étendue que
qu'ils jouent depuis si longtemps donc
pour eux c'est c'est plus simple de se
préparer contre nous et bon on n'est
quand même pas très fort quoi enfin
beaucoup moins que les autres donc c'est
dur quoi moins expérimentée en tout cas
c'est sûr alors deux points c'est pas
une bonne performance c'est pas terrible
maintenant tu vas retirer beaucoup de ce
tournoi ouais ouais mais j'espère quoi
j'ai essayé de grâce à ça de de gagner
un petit peu des points ils ont
maintenant j'ai pris un petit peu
d'expérience sana a aussi redonné envie
de jouer aux échecs parce que bon hein
cette année c'était pas pas fantastique
mais bon c'était très intéressant quoi
d'accord alors pour conclure avec leur
guide arrive la formule bella formule
j'ai pas tellement à vis personnellement
j'aurais préféré jouer quatre parties de
plus mais c'est pour toujours pour
l'expérience quoi sinon bon je pense
quand même qu'un comme tout or en 15
parties c'est plus équitable d'accord
alors avant de me tourner vers
jean-claude loubatière je vais mentionné
le classement je pense qu'on ne connaît
pas encore le résultat de la partie de
christian bauer
on va les français ne le connais pas
encore donc pour l'instant le classement
provisoire etienne bacrot premier c'est
sûr avec 8 points donc champion de
france et aussi vu dortmund 2e avec 7
points c'est sûr
ensuite on à jean-marc degraeve avec 6
points et demi igor nataf avec six
points
freyssinet cinq et demi et genre en
écorce cinq et demi anatoly walser
premier de la poule basse avec 6 points
ex-aequo avec manuela pis elle a six
points aussi et loire aux langes donc
ces voix là c'est moi ex-aequo avec
robert fontaine et darko à nietzsche
avec 5 points donc troisièmes ex-aequo
de la poule basse david marciano la
grosse contre-performance de ce tournoi
qui n'est pas venu nous voir ce soir a
fait quatre points et demi - 16 points
elo donc c'est une c'est la contre
performance de ce tournoi guillaume
valin trois points et demi et laurent
guitard et lido points donc voilà on a
mentionné les 16 joueurs il reste encore
donc arnaud hauchard et donc
christian bauer qui sont en train de
jouer partie décisive donc notamment
pour les qualifications au zonal et aux
olympiades et donc on va tout de suite
enchaîné donc avec monsieur loubatières
bonsoir
manser alors voilà que résultat final
était une banque au champion de france
c'est bien c'est bien je crois qu'il a
mérité son titre et que le disant le
championnat était beaucoup plus
intéressant que l'an dernier
passionnant donc les les spectateurs ont
montré l'intérêt puisque la salle était
pleine
tout au long du tournoi n'y a pas de
comparaison avec ce qui se passait à
besançon ou à méribel ya deux ans donc
tournoi un fantastique avec des joueurs
qui beaucoup de joueurs qui se battent
qui a pris des risques et donc c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il faut donc une
bonne organisation en tout cas des beaux
joueurs que dire sur la formule puisque
on a une fois de plus sur les formules
donc là là je l'aimais trop ça vous en
tant qu'organisateur de l'événement
puisque on a vu les avis des joueurs
apparemment tout le monde préfère 15
secondes ça ça reste un discuter quoi en
fait je pense que les dix ans sporting
on veut on voulait deux choses
premièrement que le classement soit
sportivement juste est ce que c'est le
cas oui bien sûr regarder les
performances des joueurs
c'est exactement l'ordre du classement
donc ça c'était très important et ce
n'était pas le cas l'an dernier avec les
demi finales et la finale ça c'est clair
deuxièmement on voulait quelque chose
qui soit spectaculaire tournée la phase
finale c'était fantastique
on lève la phase préliminaire était
vraiment très très intéressante en
particulier les rangs de 6,7
parce qu'il faut jouer pour se qualifier
et ensuite on arrive avec quatre parties
qui sont chaque fois il ya des chocs
chaque fois la salle est pleine et je
crois que c'est quand même ce qu'il faut
regarder
bon le tout rond mais bon c'est une idée
ancienne c'est bien mais
n'oublions pas méribel n'oublions pas
les éditos qui pleuvaient un petit peu
partout et qui se plaignait des nullités
rapide et les joueurs qui disaient oui
mais 15 ronan est bien obligé de faire
des nuls bon c'était pas passionnant
méribel c'est clair donc je crois que le
pari est gagné que à la réflexion la
formule était intéressante
la formule était assez sportive
notamment ont notamment le je pense que
l'on peut dire que le niveau des échecs
français a pro passé et que là le
tournoi était extrêmement ouvert cette
année il n'y avait pas vraiment de
favori puisque un joueur comme igor
nataf christian bauer laurent frayssinet
voire même donc voire même entre
guillemets genre en écosse qui a fait
qu'il est ici prouvé qu'on pouvait qu'on
pouvait faire des miracles et bien en
tout cas sont tous capables de d'aller
chercher etienne bacrot il oscille
tordjman puisque ils ne sont ils ne sont
pas vraiment pas là des danses tendre
oui tout à fait je crois qu'en plus bas
en dix ans les joueurs ont pris des
risques par exemple je pense que hier
jean-marc de grève a dû refuser une
proposition de nullité de iossif
d'organes
il a perdu incite donc le le tournoi
sportivement été très disputée et
etienne l'a gagné en remportant d'abord
sa partie contre laurent frayssinet et
puis comme christian bauer je crois que
c'est là qu'il a qu'il a bâti sa
victoire il faut signaler que il a joué
contre deux joueurs qui jouaient donc
laurent avec des blancs n'a pas joué
pour faire nul il a joué pour gagner et
c'est bien et christian aussi a pris
beaucoup de risques dans cette partie
oui donc un tournoi c'est vrai cette
année en tout cas assez combatif avec
des très bons joueurs
l'équipe de france à prévoir pour les
olympiades
comment va-t-elle être constitués ou en
tout cas qui est qui est pressenti pour
participer à l'issue de ce championnat
de france à 10 ans les trois premiers
d'ici donc etienne bacrot iossif dorfman
puis le troisième qui pourraient être
amenées aux charges puisque il reste
quelques minutes à jouer mais je crois
qu'il a alors nous un petit peu retourné
la position il était très mal quand
christian mais maintenant il est je
crois qu'il est mieux je pense qu'il va
gagner et donc les trois plus plus qui
m'allait les joueurs sélectionnés par un
comité de sélection
alors donc la porte est ouverte bon le
premier auquel il faut penser c'est joël
lautier
toutefois je lethielleux seconde main de
crabes nique pour ce match contre
kasparov match qui s'achève le 4
novembre
donc les olympiades commence le 28
octobre se termine le 12 octobre 12
novembre pardon donc il y a deux options
ou alors je vais le tien ne vient pas du
tout ou alors il ya quand même une autre
option c'est que joël viennent pour les
dernières parties donc ça c'est s'aider
des choix à faire en accord avec les
joueurs et puis avec le team pour le
tournoi zonal donc par contre c'est les
5 premiers donc a priori ça ne posera
pas de problème je crois que tous les
joueurs napout lot à l'exception de jean
rené corps qui ne peut pas jouer ce
tournoi vents seront un monde d'harry ce
samedi prochaine pour faire des zones à
l'est puis à gagner leur place pour new
delhi bien et new delhi champion du
monde donc le championnat de france est
effectivement auto rectification c'est
également l'occasion d'avoir le doublé
d' etienne bacrot qui montre une fois de
plus un record de précocité comigne
joueurs qui ont joué dans l'intégralité
du tournoi puisqu'il ya pas que le
national 944 joueurs de nouveaux records
non c'est pas le deuxième
mais lorsqu'un deuxième meilleur score à
la 75e édition ça va crescendo cet
ingénieur puis par contre meilleur score
au niveau des des moyennes et l'eau dans
le national national féminin dans
l'accession et puis déjà une pluie de
normes quatre normes déjà de réaliser
dans les normes dans le tournoi national
féminin 4 nord de maître international
féminin
donc c'est évidemment unique et
peut-être la possibilité d'avoir quatre
joueuses ex-aequo à la première place
demain
en fait mon mari ce bug est quand même
favoris tels à un point de lens
mais s'il lui arrivait de perdre contre
anne muller 20 il n'est pas exclu qu'il
y ait quatre chaises à égalité quelque
chose à égaliser dont claude assurée
prévient quatre normes une ronde avant
la fin c'est tout à fait exceptionnel le
niveau était également très relevé donc
bon alors un mot pour conclure ce
championnat de france
je crois que c'est un grand champion de
france et une confirmation championne
français l'événement dernier dans les
échecs français c'est aussi à coup sûr
le plus beau championnat national qui
existent dans le monde au niveau échec
et puis cette année nous avons vu nous
avons eu un plus n'est-ce pas canal web
eh bien je crois qu'on va on va conclure
là dessus puisque ça m'a l'air d'être
une très bonne conclusion
donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission merci au public merci à la
fédération nous avoir accueillis dont
canal web à vichy s'est terminée et on
vous donne rendez vous pour la prochaine
vendredi évidemment tous les vendredis
21h en direct sur internet
www.canalsat.fr slash et rs6 la
diagonale pour html
le rendez vous des joueurs d'échecs et
merci et au revoir
m